get these emojis
hi I'm Greg hey stop I'm Amy
we're gonna watch the emoji trailer
today oh I'm doing all my emojis later
right yeah the higher the higher but I
didn't go have anyone feel like the
lecture my likes a lot with the tears oh
yeah or sad Florida oh yeah yeah yeah or
like oh you're working out muscle oh use
that I use the clap and I use this I was
like praise praise the universe and it's
like two thousand other more emojis you
could choose from
amy capital [ __ ] go check out her
YouTube channel it's a lot a lot of fun
I have an upcoming video that we shot it
already weary dishes and mismanage isn't
one day that's kind of like semi travel
food blog so I'm going to check it out
once it stops us we gotta go subscribe
now she's be notified right hey we're
gonna watch the emoji movie trailer yet
she said she said to me she hasn't seen
any of these yet no small little bit
preview for you all right Justin easy
man McAllister what should I say just
play it cool
welcome to the world inside your phone
for everyone suspected to have one wave
their whole life and I'm supposed to be
at men max who carry my problem is I
have more than one emotions like this
though please tell me you weren't
laughing just now
what'd you get sent out on the phone
making the wrong your face I'll make the
right face when I would finally fit in
please you're so handsome when you make
back things I think it's ready now
hmm are you there Alex we have an income
exactly we are go for Metro huh what the
heck - the loser lounge where the emojis
you never get used for some type aah aah
I'm gonna Muji the guy have some sort of
purpose here I'm gonna help you we need
to get off the phone and find the source
code then I can fit in that's wrong
bye Felicia this is open dream again
it was Tina Kali Sarah I want to say
wheat pizza but that doesn't feel right
now I'm sailing out I think you're
pretty cool just going
[Music]
these are huge
maybe meant to have more than just one
of those the mattock you run in another
piece of candy ever again high-five
don't do it don't you do it or even in
there one some folks we threw up do we
go for tea should wash our hands I'm
really excited for that more than I
thought I was going to be yeah I mean
inside out to looks at me I know and
wreck-it Ralph
yeah and a little hint of Toy Story in
there I'd say I get a lot more which we
call it inside out vibe so much inside
out you know pretty much it's pretty
much instead of the brain yeah yeah yes
which is gonna appeal more towards it's
like hey let's take inside out and
appeal more to kids I guess I mean I'm a
little concerned that it will just be a
bunch of it's going to be a lot of puns
a lot give you a lot of puns but they
hold together like some of the greatest
comedians and voice actress DJ Oh Jim
Miller's I'm James Corden and my Rudolph
and those rides I bet yeah I can see it
working I just you know there's been
like [ __ ] and I made the Angry Birds
movies oh I didn't even
how was that I saw some
it's like are they actually is a
dialogue is a script actually going to
be good or is it just going to play on
the fact that it's the emoji movie all
times they're gonna actually be anything
I mean it looks like they're really
trying to create a story here that very
that's more than just an emoji animated
world oh this is this is art it's like
the kind of Toy Story is to me to write
where o is like the emojis or an actual
life being that I hold in my hand if
you're going to do something like inside
out I think one of the best aspects of
inside out was the balance of primarily
focusing on the personality the emotions
inside of inside in inside the brain
right but also cutting back to the
actual human being which I love yeah I
love that too being a guy who struggles
often with knowing what emoji to use
because I'm you never know who's gonna
miss communicate or if it's you to come
across too strong or not strong enough
to its emojis are a whole other form of
communication texting was already hard
enough for me right that was one emotion
to encapsulate how you're feeling yeah
yeah and I don't know that but
surprisingly the part of the chair that
drew me and most was whenever I they
showed the teenage boy who is struggling
with what emojis to put your that's the
part I really relate he picked it up
like maybe I can learn some insider
information from them yeah yeah other
than that it's the same gimmick as
insight yeah yeah was like oh you're
this emotion so your whole personality
and jokes are all based off that emotion
right so there's some rip off stuff to
it however if you're going to do an
emoji movie this is probably your best
route you could take time out Mansell
yeah but also this must be have been in
production like wow and find out was
still in production so it's almost like
you wonder if they were already like one
magic you know like saying is it was
already in production so I don't know
how they would have stolen it - that
would have been really interesting a lot
ago but do you think I don't think who
do dream worries like Sony sorry yeah I
don't think Sony Pictures animations
take as long
see I'm thinking like three years yeah a
car is like a decade's worth of time
emoji boobs crap everything is my my
thing is like it could still work it
could still be pretty funny when I saw
the other trailers it didn't look that
funny this was much better than any of
the other teasers okay so and I love TJ
Miller and he's the commentary going on
they've got such a good cast
yeah it's emojis people are gonna be
able to relate to it there's gonna be
some funny like haha [ __ ] jokes and
hopefully its meaning
hopefully it's not just cookies every
time there should be like a naked man
emoji called porn I can't spend porn I
can't and what about you do use those
thumbs up about that
no heart I already is alright wait three
different that's my right colored heart
the mint I use I use the bicycle a lot
of fun
I use a monkey and the black guy face
apparently I don't know I use the cowboy
are angry along as well this is an
inside look at Greg's emotions yeah when
I'm having like a serious text fight I
use attention by sending in angry hell
with you very relatable to a lot
especially as the Millennials a little
little Millennials are all about this
what the hell one who now I'm talking
like it old for young was not Daniel the
baby boomers out alright guys okay
thanks for spending that our way I know
why you've already put theirs up but I'm
late to the show that's why they're
wrong the ever Late Show with Greg Alba
subscribe to the real rejects then click
that notification Bel Ami
capsule Wow is on sand castle Inc or
it's a me caps pipe and a me cats will
make your life a lot easier go check out
our awesome YouTube oh I got
I got that yeah I got it recently watch
the pastry on got fun exclusive videos
on their mini vlogs behind the scenes
cutout cakes and footage so much fun
stuff on there and a lot more rewards
than just video stuff I mean we get I
sent a letter to someone a personal
librarian John and I spent a half hour
I'd like you hand-wrote it camera sondra
wanted this hand this hand this has Greg
Alba head I signed it oh gee and
Gabrielle because you have to pay a
hundred fifty five dollars and get my
full name an extra letter and it's not
what it was yeah I charge $50 alone I
only have a my no you'd only make like
cheap based on mine what I charge you'd
only make like 80 bucks